elon musk
asks putin if he wants to have a
conversation with him on clubhouse
can you imagine hey uh vladimir putin
you know will you please come and join
me on clubhouse
you speak russian no i don't speak
russian i've had
russian friends but i don't speak
russian okay so teslacio elamos on
saturday as russian president vladimir
putin if he was interested in having a
conversation on clubhouse the up and
coming social media platform that
connects people via audio chat
audio chat musk tweeted directly to the
official twitter account
of the president of russia asking would
you like me join me in the clubhouse
he followed that with a tweet entirely
in russian that transit it would be a
great honor to speak with you kremlin
called musk's idea for putin to join
clubhouse app
interesting seeking details kremlin
spokesperson dimitri pescov told
reporters on a conference call in
general this is
this is of course a very interesting
proposal but we need to understand what
is
what it's meant what it's being proposed
first we need to check then we will
react we want to figure it out first
president putin does not want
does not personally use social networks
directly he doesn't have them peskov
said so what what
what's this about you said something
about musk every day there seems to be a
what with muslims there's a big story
he's moving the market he's doing
something he clearly knows it he knows
the power he has
he he's the most influential person on
the planet right now i mean outside of
politics probably you have to go i don't
know
i don't think so i think you're more so
outside of politics the only reason i
say that is because some mad men may
have a
finger on a nuclear bomb so that's a lot
of influence if you can just go nuts and
wipe out half the world
outside of some extreme behavior like
that he's the most influential person in
the world
every not not almost every every
day any tweet he sends out is news
it's big news and people are so blindly
following him they will do whatever he
says
i guarantee you there are 10 million
people trying to buy stock in russia
because he sent out that tweet yesterday
even though that's not a company okay i
guarantee you they're calling their
brokers they're going on
robin hood real estate property
head's spinning right now because
usually i am the one with the ulterior
motive
yeah is that german or russian i don't
even know that's germany i'm terrible at
exiting tom
don't go the accents okay do what you do
okay so you know what
musk knows it the question i was
wondering to myself because i'm always
writing these stories on vt post
because anything elon musk if he says
something about bitcoin hey he bought
one point or he invested 1.5 billion
into bitcoin
he said he liked etsy one time the stock
went nuts the next day
even when he promotes a different stock
like a solar wind company
maybe the the nasdaq ticker sign isn't
real common so if you twist one letter
around
that company will go up 15 in one day
he's got he's such a big thinker i think
there has to be 15 documentaries done on
him i don't know how he does it
you know he's coming to miami and
digging a tunnel for 30 million
they thought it was going to cost a
billion he's going to alleviate traffic
now for 30 million with his boring
company he's doing it in vegas
spacex just launched new rockets today i
mean i don't know how he does it but
he's got
he's not going to reach out to him
without a reason he wants to build a
plant in russia
right he wants to open up russia to
tesla it's a market for him that he's
not into yet and he probably wants to
find a cheap place
to build more cars over there but it
clearly caught putin
off guard on his heels a little bit and
you're not used to seeing him
react like that but he knows it's an
opportunity because if must call
something good
is on the other line probably wait wait
before check out this this
is this was before and after elon's
tweet
and that's not even what he said he
tweeted uh use signal which is like an
encrypted app
um when whenever whatsapp announced that
they would
start storing the data and then people
went
rushed to buy a public traded company
which is called signal but completely
different company
and you just see it jump from what
you're at 60 cents
to seven bucks and by the way it stayed
up after that if you actually give them
credit
it went from being like a 20 cent
company to three dollars that maintained
it
so what what do you got to say about i
mean tom hit it right on the head i mean
he
moves the market just with a tweet with
any single comment three points to make
here on this entire story
number one have we ever seen a business
rock star like
elon musk i mean steve jobs was never a
rock star bill gates not a rock star
warren buffett nah not really buddy even
someone like richard branson like that
guy
pales in comparison to elon musk i can't
think jobs is the closest part yeah but
he was never i mean jobs you know rest
and rest in power but he
i'm just saying he was the closest i'm
not saying right right but he's nowhere
on elon's level in terms of like the
influence and what he's doing now there
was no twitter there was no
none of that but he was a rock star he
would they but he had a call he was a
private person he was a private yeah he
wasn't out there but point is
elon musk is business rock star social
media doing it all moving markets
that's the number one closest thing to
him when you said like a businessman
like that is tony stark there is nothing
he's the only and it's a movie yeah so
it's iron man that's the closest thing
to elon musk
so that's what we needed to go to the
irony is that tony stark was based off
of
none other than elon musk was he really
and that's elon musk ten years ago uh
robert downing jr
went visited elon musk when he was
developing how the character was going
to
be
on marvel so there did you know that no
that part i don't know so you just
intuition it's like your your batman
senses just yeah he's right behind me
he's right behind you gives me
he's giving you a look so that's number
one so point number two number two it's
great yeah point number two vladimir
putin not have social media
nothing that's russia i don't know
nothing i don't have i don't even know
he's probably interviewing russian wives
right now that's why he knows this is
how
he's talking to the bro yes
social media that's pretty intense no
social media whatsoever no
you know rotus uh you know president of
the russia whatever the hell it is
nothing okay i mean and then the third
point here
is clubhouse clubhouse wasn't even a
thing six months ago i never heard of it
we just heard about it recently well no
they just raised a hundred million
dollars they're valued at a billion
dollars now and they they've had things
going on but yeah but i'm sure they
existed mark and recently
there's a lot of people that are on
there that i've never heard of clubhouse
until i started being
with valuetainment less than six months
sure is when i heard about it and you
said oh you invited me you said here it
joined this it was like three months ago
yeah
but that is the platform that elon musk
invites
vladimir putin to do the interview
pretty intense so those are the three
things elon musk rockstar
vladimir no social media and the rise of
clubhouse by the way if you can get in
clubhouse get in clubhouse because right
now it's only worth a billion and
they're going to go this
this is a idea that could go too what do
you mean get in
if you can get in investment-wise it's
this
not given recommendation i'm just saying
if you similar to a bitcoin
similar to any of those things take a
look at clubhouse in a different way
than just
a uh uh platform sure well let me tell
you this even if it's 5 10 20 50 000
i asked you recently pat who would you
love to interview that you have never
interviewed you said
putin you said putin yeah of course why
putin when did i tell you that
a couple weeks ago why not two weeks ago
kgb why not those stories oh we've
reached out to putin already yeah we
talked to their cam
we talked at account regularly i know
this better be david we uh and we'd like
to do a live interview it wouldn't be a
yeah it wouldn't be a clubhouse why
would you select putin out of everybody
in the world i think
he is the most powerful man in the world
today wow i don't think it's biting most
powerful are you kidding me like over
the
chinese president guys over she over uh
let me let me put it to you this way
strategy okay
so don't take away what's the best way
to put this
okay uh has popovich ever had a
kobe a lebron a jordan a shack
a kareem has he ever had a player like
almost duncan duncan's not a top five
though okay no okay
so would you put duncan top ten or top
twenty no top twenty i would have i'm
with twenty
i'm with you but he's never
this is about he never had a michael a
kobe
a lebron a shark okay a game changer so
who had two of them who had three of
them
phil had three of them twice let me ask
you this what if you take those three
out i don't know what phil would be yeah
and what if you gave those three to pop
i don't know what pop would be i don't
know what lenny wilkins would be if he
had a
i don't know what lenny wilkins is a
thousand win guy i don't know what larry
brown would be we don't know this kind
of stuff
wow take away the country of china
russia us
take purely leadership don't take
resources of course china and u.s
resources are ahead who's the best
strategist amongst those three
oh you're kidding me putin will do lamps
between those two other guys yeah and
it's his kgb background i mean wouldn't
you like to dive into that you would do
laps
okay if there's a fist fight who wins
putin
if there's a sleepy joke wait a second
biden's got a crutch in his hand arcane
you guys does that counts
that guy right in the chest that it's
over you guys are so funny no
putin is uh putin is uh uh taking
putin in a fight well it's putin because
who poses shirtless it's putin
poses shirtless on top of a horse and
he's just like hey you guys want to do
something you know is any of that just
for show for optics
i highly doubt that now listen man you
can't be a okay
so listen as every country has dirt in
it
i mean dirty politics yeah which country
things got dirtier politics
russia okay can you imagine dirtiest
surviving and leading a dirty
politics country type of thing that's
that that kind of
you have to be able to know how to play
the game he's been the president for 20
years now how do you do that
how do you do that and maintain power
for that long with he poisons his
enemies how many people
poisoned want to throw you under the bus
and he still maintained it
you got to give the guy well he handled
all the ogle arks in that country
all the people that by the way i'm not
endorsing the system don't take it as an
endorsement this is not in
i'm just telling you he is the most
powerful person right now wow yeah
so that's your selection of who you'd
love to see so now i got a weird
question for you guys i got a weird
question for you guys here's my weird
question for you
so we just talked about the era of old
people then we talked about elon musk
and we talked about elon musk inviting
putin then you said every day elon musk
is relevant
okay is elon musk one
dumb tweet away from being suspended and
permanently suspended from twitter
that's the question
okay i'm gonna well you want an answer
right i'm curious i'm gonna say no
i would say he's got more leash than one
dumb because he's good for twitter
all right every time you hear about elon
being in the news it's because of
twitter
trump was bad for twitter for twitter
business-wise
okay i'm just answering the question you
asked i do not believe he's
one dumb tweet away i think he's earned
enough equity where he could have two
or three he's not dumb enough to do it
or he has the same
card that he'll be forgiven both he's
clearly not that stupid where he's gonna
do something like that can i make two
other points about musk real quickly
number one
um it was 11 degrees in moscow yesterday
and eight degrees in austin texas so
maybe he wants to move there who knows
that's why he called putin
number two though seriously you know you
think about social media influencers or
people that have
influence that have a following that
people respond to what do brands do for
them they bring them
money so they post right it pushes the
brand makes them money
elon musk is immune to that like an
insider trading situation hey can you do
one tweet on my company it'll blow up
he's already the richest person in the
world there's no financial benefit for
him
individually to ever do something
because you'd always ask yourself
when you have that much power and that
much sway and so many disciples that
will do whatever you say to do with
a five-word tweet are you susceptible to
being bribed
insider trading taking something that's
unethical or doing something and using
that power in a negative way he could
never do it for financial reasons
because he doesn't have to he's already
the richest guy in the world
would twitter ever ban elon musk that's
the question
yes right because it's a two it's a
two-prong question
one is would he ever post something
dumb enough that would jeopardize him
staying on
twitter and number two would twitter
ever have the audacity
to say we were permanently banned i
think if he does do that just going on
track record
i'm gonna have to say yes why would i
say yes number one
he's done some stupid stuff that has
moved uh look
for all the kudos that were given elon
musk he's also done stuff that has hurt
the brand and the stock
like i could see either the you know uh
board of directors or even self-imposed
being like dude put down the twitter for
a second i could see that
you he went on joe rogan podcast smoked
a blunt that did not help the company
i could see that thing and then if
twitter has any track record
for silencing voices especially more
conservative voices and i i
politically i think that elon musk is
center right
right i don't know how far right he is
he's certainly not a leftist or anything
like that
i think he's more center-right he's
obviously a capitalist for sure
can i see him saying something so
outlandish or so
from his perspective what he thinks is
right
but you know the leftist whoever's
controlling twitter
thinks is wrong i think it could happen
uh do i want it to happen am i rooting
for elon musk am i rooting for
his companies and you know space travel
hell yeah
but based on track record things that
he's said and what twitter has done or
social media
has done to write leaning voices it's
possible yes do
you what do you think so so here's how i
process that here's how i process this
when you get a person like that that is
that eccentric mind non-stop working
you know take mark take a howard hughes
okay
and take tony stark the character howard
hughes real character
tony stark you know fictional character
iron man right the
robert downey jr okay there was a part
about
the girl that plays in iron man that
dude just shut your mouth
and stay down here don't say anything to
the media i don't know if you remember
that relationship
yes yes well she's kind of like dude
just don't say anything you get in front
of mike's like ah screw it here's what
i'm doing you know what we're going
dude just be quiet right does musk like
is musk the kind of guy that behind
closed doors
you tell him not to say something he
won't say it i don't think so
i think if musk wants to say something
he'll say now let me flip it
so so i do think there's an element of
that let me go to a different direction
howard hughes is there an element of a
musk that he could get bored out of his
mind that he may want to do something
crazy
i don't know you know he he's gonna in
his brain like he sees things that the
world doesn't see yeah he sees the world
from a different place
but i have a neural link but i'll give
you the last one here i'll give you the
last one here why i don't think it would
happen
here's what i don't think it would
happen i don't think it would happen
because he came from the paypal mafia
community
and that entire community is all
connected okay and they all work
together yeah and somebody would make
the call and say elon just so you know
they're going to get a slap and you
we're going to have to spend you for
like a day or something but you're going
to get back on just
don't do that again bro like you ain't
helping yourself okay you know and then
he's going to go back to what he's doing
because he came from that so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye